ROGER MARTINEZ: You might have
heard of the principle of least
privilege--
everyone should only be
granted the minimum permissions
that are needed to
perform their jobs.
Grant too much access and
you've created a security risk.
Grant too little access
and, soon enough, you'll
be inundated with
support tickets
from users requesting
that you grant
them access to do their jobs.
It's a balancing act between
security and developer
productivity, and it's
one of those things that's
easier said than done.
On Google Cloud,
there is a boatload
of IAM roles loaded with dozens
of individual permissions
for a wide array of
APIs and services.
Google Cloud Active Assist
has a whole category
of tools under the
security umbrella
called Policy Intelligence.
Policy Intelligence
uses data and machine
learning to help you
optimize your IAM policies,
troubleshoot access
issues, better predict
the impact of any permission
changes across your project
or organization, and
simplify access reviews.
Let's do a quick walkthrough
of the services and tools that
make up Policy Intelligence
by imagining a few scenarios
and asking a few questions
that might come up.
Let's say that you've got
a Cloud storage bucket that
has some sensitive data in it.
Question-- who in
my organization
can read the files
in this bucket?
Answer that with Policy
Analyzer, which can tell you
which user accounts,
service accounts, and groups
have certain roles
and permissions
on a specific
resource, including
access gained through service
account impersonation.
OK, how about this?
You've got a new employee
joining the team who actually
does need to use the
files in that bucket,
but it looks like
they can't access them
with their user account.
The question-- why can't
they access the bucket?
The answer to this one is found
with Policy Troubleshooter.
You give it an email, a
resource, and a permission,
and Policy Troubleshooter will
examine the IAM policies that
apply to the resource to reveal
whether any of the user's roles
include the required
permissions.
It will also tell
you whether or not
the user is in a group
that has those permissions.
Next, you're doing an audit
of your project's IAM roles
and permissions and
find that there's
a service account
that's been used in one
of your application's backends.
First, how do you make sure that
this service account is still
needed?
For that, there's
Activity Analyzer.
Activity Analyzer lets you
see when your service accounts
and keys were last used
to call a Google API.
With the dates of the most
recent authentication activity,
you can more easily
identify service accounts
and service account keys
that may no longer be in use
and safe to
deactivate or delete.
OK, what if you learn that, yes,
the service account is still
in use, but it's
also overprovisioned
with extra permissions
you think it doesn't need?
What would happen if you
swapped out one of those roles
for a more restricted one?
Answer?
Well, you could just make the
change and see what breaks.
But that's probably not
the best course of action.
Instead, you can use Policy
Simulator to simulate a policy
change to make sure
nothing breaks,
and apply the change if you're
satisfied with the results.
This removes the risk
of accidentally breaking
an application or
process by removing
a role that you incorrectly
thought was unnecessary.
Finally, when it comes to the
principle of least privilege,
there's one more question
that you might have.
How do I start and make
progress when I have
lots of overprovisioned roles?
Well, here's a great answer--
IAM Recommender.
These are recommendations
that automatically surface
on your Cloud
Console, letting you
know when accounts
may be overprovisioned
with too many permissions.
These recommendations are
based on actual usage data
and include alternative roles
that you can grant instead
with just a couple of clicks.
Recommendations are
updated constantly,
and you have the option of
dismissing them or applying
them.
And, even after that, you can
easily roll back the changes.
Together, these tools make
up Active Assist Policy
Intelligence that makes
applying the principle of least
privilege less of a burden.
In the next couple of
videos in the series,
I'm going to dig a little
deeper into each of these tools
so that you can get familiar
with what they're capable of
and understand when you
would use each of them.
In the meantime, if you want
to learn more about Policy
Intelligence, check out
cloud.google.com/policy
intelligence.